a man alleged to be the fourth member of
a terror cell known as the beatles has
been arrested in the uk on terror
charges 38 year old ain davis was
arrested tonight after arriving into
luton airport on a flight from turkey
he was arrested in relation to offenses
under we're told sections 15 17 and 57
of the terrorism act he was detained by
officers from the metropolitan police's
counterterrorism command and is now
being held at a police station in south
london well davis is said to have denied
that he was part of the betel cell so
nicknamed because of their english
accents which tortured and beheaded
western hostages in syria while cell
ringleader mohammed emwazi widely known
as jihadi john was killed in a drone
strike back in 2015.
londoner alexander cote was jailed in
the u.s in april for his part in the
torture and murder of american hostages
and his co-defendant el shafiel sheikh
will be sentenced in august for his role
in the plot so aim davis apparently
being questioned right now in a police
station in south london